hey youtubers it's Charlie so yesterday
in my Game of Thrones review I seem to
submit all of your biggest questions so
I picked 10 of them to answer in this
video with one bonus question I think we
were all in agreement that Peter
Dinklage was the high point with you
know shape being the low point first
things first though congratulations to
storm Ragnarok you are this week's
random giveaway winner you win a $20
Amazon gift card I'll reach out to you
on your channel for details but if
you're finding me for the first time
just as a way to say thank you to all
you guys for being so awesome each week
I just do a random giveaway also because
there's a ton of stuff happening this
week I'm going to be posting a few more
videos than I normally do I added a link
to my master schedule for what I'm gonna
upload stuff down in the description
below be sure to subscribe to get
everything
there's gonna be a lot of cool stuff now
let's answer some questions so careful
for spoilers from the episode if you
haven't seen it yet but number one the
swedish dude asks that's awesome name do
you think we'll learn more about the
other important people in marine soon
since we saw his door in episode 6 I
think there's a pretty good chance we
will meet some other people
Daenerys hasn't gotten any super long
scenes in the last couple of episodes so
she's due for something big soon most of
the focus right now is all around
turians trial so after that passes I
think we'll get at least one long myrin
episode before the finale the show has
this really weird habit where it likes
to end seasons with really big Daenerys
moments you know with the exception of
season two which was that white Walker
shot that doesn't guarantee season 4
will end on a Daenerys moment but I do
think it would be funny if there was
this meta thing going on where each
season's end rotated between fire and
ice you know fire being Daenerys and ice
being stuff going on up at the wall I
guess the show has kind of been doing
that because season 1 ended on Daenerys
season 2 up in the North season 3 on
Daenerys so I guess that would mean that
we're gonna end on a white Walker or
something up in the north this season
too but let me know what you think and
start your theorycrafting now question
number 2 starlight asks what was various
motivations to testify against Tyrion if
they were friends yeah the interesting
thing about that is is that Varys and
Tyrion are still on the same side they
both want to do what's best for King's
Landing but I think that Varys testified
against him because he felt it was more
important to his long-term goals of
strengthening the realm you know more
important than say the short-term goal
of rescuing Tyrion Varys is totally
willing to throw people under the bus if
it helps his long-term plans that's why
he's just
dangerous is littlefinger although I
think Varys is a little bit more noble
in his goals he's not trying to win the
throne for himself I did see a lot of
confusion in the comments after the
episode because he looked at the throne
whenever it was talking to Oberon but
the throne is just a metaphor for his
plan he doesn't actually want to be king
himself the really important thing to
remember though is that Varys did say he
never forgets anything so he does want
to help tyrion i think he just felt that
you know speaking out against Cersei in
the trial would have hurt things rather
than help them question number three
Adam Thomas asks WTF Shae yet that was
actually one of the biggest you know
comment comments that I saw after the
episode let's forget about the books for
a second and just think about what her
character has been doing on the show I
saw two things going on first she did
look like she was trying to hurt Tyrion
she was intentionally testifying you
know no one was holding a sword to her
throat but two it also looked like
Cersei had some sort of involvement
shake glanced in her direction several
times whenever she was testifying
remember a couple of weeks ago Circe's
handmaiden heard Shae and Tyrion arguing
and we never really followed up on that
moment so it's possible that certain
just learned something and is trying to
coerce Shae into testifying by offering
her something in return that being said
I think she still loves Tyrion she's
just really headstrong and does not care
at all about the other politics going on
at King's Landing Tyrion has been in
this really awkward place politically
all season you know having to deal with
Sansa and avoid getting murdered at
every moment he's been walking on
eggshells all season and shade does not
care about any of that I don't think
that she fully realizes what's going to
happen to Tyrion if he's convicted so if
you really want to blame shape for
something just blame her for ignorant of
all the politics and what's going on
right now question number four cassie
prior asks do you think we'll see any of
the other Greyjoy uncle's this season
yeah there has not been a lot of great
joy this season they never really
announced any castings for any of the
uncles so the chances are pretty slim
we're gonna see any of them but the moat
Cailin Ramsay snow plot does deal with
the Ironborn so it's possible that they
could be involved
the producers haven't made any
announcements so it is unlikely if
you're not familiar with the other
Greyjoy uncles they're basically just
other secondary characters that exist in
the books but you know because the show
has a habit of kind of cutting out some
of those characters like the brave
companions or strong Bell wasps it's
possible that they could just be giving
the lines that those uncle's had to
other characters that are already on the
show question number five
Lenny asks when will they start casting
season five so usually we start to hear
casting news starting in the summer
tentatively I plan to hear a few things
around Comic Con in July they usually
don't cast everyone at once either so
they'll be announcing new people all the
way into the fall the half started
scouting locations though which is one
of the first things they do before they
cast people and start preparing episodes
a lot of you have also been asking me
about Doran too about whether or not
we're gonna see any scenes in Dorne
either this season or next season
obviously I'm not expecting it this
season but whenever we start hearing
where the locations that are scouting
are then we'll probably find out usually
those types of things don't stay secret
so if we find out there filming
somewhere near a desert then that means
Dorne probably
question number 6 BD destro asks what
would happen if Daenerys always let her
dragons roam free and didn't keep them
caged up and are they evil or they just
playful so based on the literature
inside the world of the show Dragons can
just keep on growing as long as they
have enough space and an unlimited food
source if you do confine them they just
won't grow as much so if Daenerys let
them roam free and live you know out in
the open where ever they wanted
potentially they just get as big as
balerion the black dread here's a
picture for scale the problem is is they
would need a massive food supply so they
would just eat everything in sight the
dragons are playful but because they're
deadly wild animals whenever they do
play they can just tear things to shreds
or incinerate them you always hear a lot
of stories about people raising wild
animals to just get too big and they
have to give them to nature preserve you
know like tigers or alligators they just
get so dangerous that they could kill
someone even if they're playing around
question number seven Andrew Jones asks
why would Theon think Yara is showing up
as a trick that's just how brainwashed
he is he is like completely mister reek
now we saw a lot of torture during
season three but Ramsay is still
psychologically abusing him so this Rick
persona has completely taken over it's
not a split personality like Gollum has
on Lord of the Rings there aren't two
separate identities living inside him
he's just completely this reek person
that lives as an appendage of Ramsay
snow he probably didn't even realize who
Yara was he probably just thought
someone was trying to kidnap him
question number eight Jamie quirk ole
asks how could Jamie Lannister
become Lord of Casterly Rock so quick so
I assume you're questioning the
practicality of just going straight from
the Kingsguard to being a regular Lord
again normally taking the oath of the
Kingsguard is a lifelong thing just like
taking the black but because Tywin
Lannister is the hand of the king in the
most powerful man in Westeros he does
whatever he wants so they're just
sweeping a lot of the traditional rules
under the rug I also saw a lot of you
asking me in the comments whether or not
I thought Jaime would have gone through
with the plan if Tyrion would have
upheld his end of it and yes I do think
he would have gone back to Casterly Rock
he does still love Cersei but I think
their sexual relationship is basically
over question number nine misty asks
does the crown know where the mountain
is right now
yes Tywin Lannister sent him to the
river Lance to cause trouble for Robb
Stark's army and the toy is back in
season two he was at Harrenhal whenever
Arya hot pie and jaqen H'ghar were there
but he kind of went rogue and started
going crazy all over the locals so Tywin
hasn't really been doing anything with
him lately but he doesn't know where he
is and the mountain is still one of his
bannermen so he'll do anything that time
what tells him to it's just that the
mountain is one of the most evil people
on the show and I think the only reason
that Tywin Lannister uses him is because
he's such an effective weapon question
number 10 Robin skee asks how did
pycelle get Sansa's necklace whenever a
Littlefinger killed him and dumped him
in the boat he dropped the necklace in
with him they were in the bay right next
to the castle so he would have drifted
to shore eventually I think that
Littlefinger meant for the authorities
to find the body and as the maester it
would have fallen on pycelle to examine
the body and one last bonus question
Claudio asks do you know when the other
books will be published so right now the
only book that has an official release
date is the world of Ice and Fire it's a
lot of the information from the wiki and
maps put together with a lot of cool
artwork it's not a novel that's being
released October 28th winds of winter
has not been announced but there has
been so many new excerpts released this
year it's possible that we could see the
book before the season 5 premiere of the
show I'm expecting that to premiere
around the same time season 4 premiered
so fingers crossed we could see the book
by spring 2015 you know maybe even
Christmas this year but I'm not
expecting it
don't be surprised though if they do
announce a release date during Comic
Cons sometime like during the game of
Thrones panel but I'm not expecting that
either that's a bit of a long shot
as for dream of spring the last book
just plan on the same amount of time it
took winds of winter to come out and use
that as an estimate so like three four
years that would be like 2018 2019 so I
think the show will probably pass the
books in season seven assuming they get
eight seasons total so thank you so much
for so many questions I always love
doing these videos it's so much fun to
answer you guys directly in a video also
because that you know schedule this week
is so crazy I posted a link to
everything in the description below so
be sure to check that out and subscribe
to get everything there's a lot of
really cool stuff happening my next
bonus video for Game of Thrones will be
a history video either on the wall or
the wildlings so right now you can click
here to get my review of episode six and
you can click here to learn all about
Braavos thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you